the government is releasing new
information about a growing scam
targeting older Americans it tricks
people into mailing cash to people
pretending to be their grandchildren
victims reportedly lose an average of
$9,000 the Federal Trade Commission says
Americans lost up to 41 million dollars
in the scam this year nearly twice as
much as last year and a Werner spoke
with an unlikely target who nearly lost
thousands of dollars I'm the last person
I thought would ever fall for a scam
like this you're the last person last
retired Tennessean Frank Stratton spent
his career working in intelligence first
for the Air Force later as a
cybersecurity programmer but his
expertise still didn't prepare him for
the scam that began with a morning phone
call in April I hear don't be don't be
afraid but I'm the public defender from
Austin Texas they have put your grandson
in jail after a wreck and he has a DUI
offense
the man said Stratton could bail out his
grandson if he sent $8,500 cash via
FedEx something that might sound
ridiculous except that struttin had
actually done just that for a family
member once in the past not only that
but the attorney briefly put his
grandson who sounded injured on the
phone so Stratton drove to the bank i've
wrote a check out and they gave me eight
thousand five hundred cash in hundreds
then he went to a local mail location to
overnight the money to an austin texas
address you know a lot of people right
now are saying at home going how could
you fall for that well it's because of
the way that they scripted it they had
it so well scripted they knew everything
about my grandson they knew everything
about me he's not the only victim the
Federal Trade Commission says people 70
and older are increasingly being scammed
and the criminals do their research
sometimes using social media to learn
more about their targets the FTC's
Monica vodkas grandparents really care
about their grandchildren the
grandchildren sound like they're in
terrible distress they're crying they
say that they've been injured frequently
and they're begging their grandparent to
help them but back in Tennessee that
night in April
Stratton says my wife and I looked at
each other and said scam just like that
just like that boom so he called FedEx
to have the package returned and while
he got his money back I'm a security
person that's what really frustrates me
because because I fell for it
even you fell for it because of love
something Stratton says every
grandparent can fall victim to for CBS
this morning and a Werner in New York
well he's sharing an important warning
he sure is and also they've gotten so
sophisticated you can see why you maybe
fell for it yeah absolutely
the FTC warns if you receive a call like
this get in touch with that family
member or friend before sending anything
and be careful about what you post on
social media because scammers can use
all of those details to create that
compelling narrative